صور لطفل مغربي هزت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ظهر فيها يجري في سباق بحذاء
ممزق
احمد ريان عمامي ظهر في صور حصدت تعاطفا
واسعا من المغاربه وهو يلف الحذاء الممزق
بشريط لاصق محاولا للحفاظ عليه في سباق
ركض به لاميال خلال بطوله وطنيه بالعاصمه
الرباط
[موسيقى]
يبلغ من العمر 11 عاما يقتل برفقه والديه
بمنزل بسيط في حي يعقوب المنصور في
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط
ومع الانتشار الكثيف لصوره وتداولها
بمواقع التواصل ظهرت موجه تعاطف كبيره من
الراي العام الرياضي المغربي وكان اول
المتفاعلين مع صوره سفيان البقالي البطل
المغربي في العاب القوى فغرد عبر حساباته
بمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي المعاربا عن
رغبته في التواصل مع الطفل
[موسيقى]
وقام ابناء الحي الذي يقتل فيها الطفل
المغربي باهدائه حذاء جديدا وبدله رياضيه
حتى يواصل وليان حلمه في ان يصبح بطلا
[موسيقى]